we are learning new details tonight
about suspected
directed energy microwave attacks
targeting cia officers
and top national security officials we
first started
hearing about them and we told you about
them here on special report in 2016.
shortly after then president obama
opened the embassy in havana cuba
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin at the pentagon has the latest
tonight about a suspected attack
here at home u.s officials say there are
now 130 suspected victims
mostly cia operatives and u.s diplomats
being treated for brain injuries
debilitating headaches and vertigo the
targets they believe of a directed
energy microwave weapon
there's a mysterious direct energy
weapon
that is being used and it is causing
in some cases permanent traumatic brain
injury
new indications suggest the incidents go
as far back as 1996
two individuals working on the nsc
believe they were targeted in 2019
and in 2020 just after the election one
was near the white house and one was
walking her dog
the russians have been working on mobile
microwave weapons for years
we have to get more information and
we've got to tell the public what's
going on the u.s
air force and tech firm papyrus have
developed a mobile high
energy microwave weapon to bring down
drones papyrus is also working on a
miniature variant of the weapon that can
be easily transported on a pickup truck
this is the type of technology that
might be targeting american diplomats
russia certainly has the means and the
motive to conduct these attacks i mean
there's some some evidence out there
that certainly points to vladimir putin
the kgb operative in the kremlin being
responsible the only victim so far to
come forward former cia head of the
europe desk
mark polymeropolis was targeted while
visiting moscow four years ago and
forced to retire
it's pretty insidious because it also
doesn't leave any kind of you know open
open scars or wounds mark lobbied for
treatment at walter reed's national
center for the intrepid
as part of his therapy he painted this
mask of a superman cape with a broken
c.i.a
shield with an arrow through it to
symbolize the moral
injury he felt when at first he was not
believed by the c.i.a
the c.i.a is now taking the issue
seriously but without the actual weapon
u.s officials don't know who to blame
and how to stop these alleged attacks
brett jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thank you we'll continue to
follow this one